so you also work with like a ton of kids
on the show is that hard to Wrangle them
all I would say that no one I have to
give credit we have uh Studio teachers
and um you have Wranglers ring yes and
ads that help keep the kids together I
do think that all of us as actors bring
a really special presence to the show
the way they react to Cheryl the way
they react to Lisa entering the room I
feel like both of these women have two
different energies of mom presence
that's right that the kids really
respect with me they really do think
with Janine's clothes and demeanor and
where I am in character that I am their
teacher they do they even think I'm a
teacher a big kid they need to listen to
so it's not really hard I have to give
our kids credit they're great they're
really good I am shocked at the way our
our casting department is able to cast
what I look at as the future of
entertainment and TV these kids are so
smart
I'm so talented yeah it's amazing and
they follow Direction first of all
Quinta gave an opportunity for a lot of
young children of color to come and be
on TV shows
before so it's a cool thing you're doing
for a lot of young hackers writers
directors all of the above and for folks
like us because we have an
intergenerational show and I love it
that you have these different women of
different ages I love that it's a
blessing
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]